oh I'm getting scared they're getting
dirtier and darker I cannot see
that's a show
first tweet
[Music]
first one Kink colon Luke Evans saying
quiver I what film that came from that's
not too bad that's fine couldn't blame
the foo for falling in love with Gaston
I mean Luke Evans is hot
oh and Gaston is hotter in that hair
Luke Evans is he on the eye and the ear
wonder if he
wonder if he tastes nice too
licks the Telly I usually smell nice
tastes nice I don't know can someone
please make me stop looking at Luke
evans's thighs and Whispering he thick
okay well that's leg day done that was
worth it I think about Luke evans's
thighs daily
Jesus interesting Luke evans's videos
are such thirst traps please put away
your muscles I'm gonna have a heart
attack don't have a heart attack
I just want to know why Luke Evans go so
[ __ ] hard in every sex scene films
like
excuse me sir some of us are already
excessively holy we don't need this
go get some
oh dear I honestly got wet just by
thinking about Luke Evans
foreign
Luke Evans could snap my back
okay
um Luke Evans could snap my back over
his knee and you know what I would thank
him afterwards
jealous of Octavia Spencer for getting
to grab Luke evans's dick
well she didn't actually it was a fake
penis but it was a very funny day can
Luke Evans be my sugar daddy please I
ain't nobody's sugar daddy I need a
sugar daddy
Luke Evans could spit on me and I'd say
thank you God bless
getting scared they're getting dirtier
and darker
I'm gonna pass on that one Luke Evans
can demolish my
redacted
I can't imagine
I just want to say that I would let Luke
Evans do disgusting things to my body
okay oh god I've come to that age now
haven't I the actual definition of daddy
is Luke Evans and my only daddy issue is
that I'm not gonna
I am not saying that my my mother can
watch this show
I still can't believe Luke Evans has IRL
vampire fangs I want him to bite my neck
and my stomach and the inside of my
thighs bye
too much information yeah
where did you find these oh my God oh my
God no no
some of these people need to get some
therapy because this is not this is not
healthy I want Luke Evans to choke slam
me through a glass table
and then call the call an ambulance
oh thank God we got to the end of that
Jesus Christ people but uh yeah okay
well you know whatever floats people's
boots you know
um thanks uh thanks for watching I hope
I've entertained you while entertaining
myself and slightly scaring myself
um watch echo three my new show out on
Apple TV Plus
[Music]
thank you